[Musique]
bonjour ita bonheur bonjour viol temps
j'adresse un bonjour chaleureux à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui nous écoutent ce
matin présidente réélue à la présidence
de l'union des femmes de la martinique
déjà un troisième mandat pour vous le
troisième mandat avec une intention rita
bonheur de mener autrement la lutte pour
les martys et l'émancipation des femmes
le respect envers l on y reviendra
mais tout d'abord sur de vrais petits
sur devait dresser la situation des
femmes en martinique on dirait quoi mais
on dirait que les inégalités persistent
aujourd'hui même si les choses avancent
l avance très très lentement
et puis donc les chiffres nous le
montrent un bond au niveau du travail de
l'emploi du chômage des filières de
formation de des inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes dans le partage des
tâches familiales enfin bon dans tous
les domaines
il y a encore de très fortes inégalités
est puis les violences envers les femmes
sont encore très très importante donc il
ya un effet lentement
pourquoi ça avance très lentement ça
avance très lentement tout simplement
parce que les mentalités prennent
beaucoup de temps pour évoluer
donc nous savons que les lois existent
dans la loi les femmes sont les égales
des hommes mais il faut et ça c'est
aujourd'hui reconnu qu'il faut changer
en profondeur les mentalités si nous
voulons que la situation réelle change
et à c'est à cela que nous nous attelons
donc vos actions ne sont pas efficaces
les actions font beaucoup je crois que
en depuis que le fn existe elle a
contribué largement à faire avancer les
mentalités à faire avancer les choses
nous avons beaucoup contribué par
exemple ces quinze dernières années a
montré que les violences envers les
femmes ce n'était pas quelque chose de
privé et qu'il fallait agir au niveau
collectif pour les faire changer mais eh
bien nous avons on va dire contre nous
et bien tout ce que la société produit
comme sexisme comme machisme comme idée
qu'ont préconçues sur les rôles des
femmes et des hommes également
alors comment mener ce combat
différemment eh bien nous avons dans ce
congrès qui a eu lieu le 8 avril défini
deux axes devraient au cours duquel vous
avez
c'est reconduite à la présidence de
l'union des femmes oui c'est avec
beaucoup de joie et beaucoup de fiat est
un que je suis j'ai été réélu mais pas
seulement puisque le bureau s'est
renforcé le bureau qui existait déjà été
reconduit et a été renforcée ce qui est
un signe aussi de dynamisme de
l'association et bien nous avons défini
deux axes verrier un premier acte qui
est celui de continuer à ancrer les
inégale et la lutte contre les violences
et l'égalité et pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes dans le paysage
martinique est à dire qu'avec les
opérations coup de poing aussi aussi
dans la sensibilisation mais nous
voulons porter l'accent justement sur
des actions de fond il s'agit pas
seulement de sensibiliser la population
mais il s'agit de mener des actions à
long terme avec des groupes avec des
personnes avec des associations avec des
structures et c'est cela que nous nous
voulons faire à travers des partenariats
que nous développons de nouvelles
stratégies de nouveaux partenaires
quelle surface brillante honneur eh bien
nous avons des associations qui
travaillent avec nous que nous
sollicitons aussi quand nous intervenons
dans les communes
nous avons également par exemple des
comités de social avec qui nous avons
fait des interventions le 8 mars dernier
et qui sont désireux de continuer avec
des rencontres débats ou des formations
nous voulons aussi bien entendu impulsé
tout ce qui est formation pour pouvoir
comprendre mieux et analyser cette
société martiniquaise et changer les
mentalités
rita bonheur est ce que les femmes
martiniquaise se mobilisent assez sur ce
genre d'action
je crois que les femmes sont de plus en
plus consciente de ces problèmes
nous sommes dans une société où quelque
chose doit se mobiliser pour que les
choses soient réellement nous sommes
dans une société aujourd'hui on a du mal
à se mobiliser parce que soit on est
pris par le quotidien quand on a des
problèmes aux rares va dire des
préoccupations quotidiennes soit parce
que bien c'est plutôt l'individualisme
qui est prôné jeudi lancer usant sur
combat féministe
il faut il faut se regrouper il faut
mettre en avant justement le collectif
et il faut être offensive et c'est ce
que nous disons c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui face à la situation que
nous vivons
il ne faut pas seulement essayé de
résister il faut être à l'offensive et
c'est d'ailleurs le mot d'ordre pour
nous trois ans à venir à l'offensive
pour un mieux-être des femmes dans une
société plus juste et plus solidaire
et puis c'est vrai qu'il ya un 2e axe
aussi qui est très important c'est celui
de des luttes sociales en général c'est
à dire que les femmes et lizeroux peut
laisser vous poser la question non mais
vous m'avez demandé alors le combat des
femmes c'est le combat de toutes les
luttes
oui tout à fait parce qu'il ne s'agit
pas seulement de se battre pour
l'égalité et contre les violences faites
aux femmes les femmes sont présentes
partout et quand on se bat pour de
meilleures conditions de travail quand
on se bat pour de meilleures conditions
de vie
quand on se bat pour de meilleures
conditions d'environnement talent et
bien les femmes sont présentes parce que
elles sont plus de la moitié de la
population est souvent elles sont
beaucoup plus touchés par les problèmes
qui se posent que les hommes
donc il faut elles sont présentes donc
il faut aussi que nous accentuerons
notre participation à ces luxueuses que
les femmes martiniquaise ont envie
d'entendre ce discours est à l'honneur
en tout cas les sympathies que nous
rencontrons autour de nous c'est bien le
véritable combat dans tous les jours
quand les femmes nous parle mais pas
seulement les femmes les hommes aussi en
sont conscients ce n'est pas un combat
c'est un combat commun avec les femmes
et avec les hommes pour faire évoluer
cette société et c'est vrai que healy a
souvent une différence entre le dire et
le faire mais aujourd'hui justement ce
que vous me fall ont acté c'est faire en
sorte que ces paroles se transforment en
véritables s est ce que le combat
féministe sera plus facile aujourd'hui
parce que c'est désormais deux
associations à mener ce combat
illégalement culture égalité l'autre
association féministe de la martinique
comment sont les relations avec 7 7
autres associations de l'union des
femmes
ben écoute et on nous a beaucoup
interpellé sur la création de sept
autres associations féministes
ça a été une période pas facile avec un
départ de l'ufm qui a été violent mais
qui dit départ dit divergences de vues
en tout cas sur des critères des
personnes qui sont parties puisque nous
n'avons mis personne dehors
il ya eu un choix de partir bon deal et
à leur aile de personnes alors il ya des
attitudes que nous n'approuvons c'est
quoi la vérité
égouttez les critères il faut leur
demander puisque ce sont elles qui sont
partis maintenant chacune et chacun a le
droit de créer notre association n'est
pas seulement chez les femmes que ça
existe chacune contribuer à sa façon à
l'évolution de la société avec ses
objectifs et ses méthodes
nous nous regardons vers l'avenir avec
nos propres objectifs et c'est ce qui
est important voilà nous sommes en
pleine période électorale rita bonheur
ce week-end ce sera le premier tour de
la présidentielle les inégalités
hommes/femmes l'accueil des femmes
victimes de violences les différences de
salaires et seront des thèmes que vous
avez vues entendues dans les programmes
des différents candidats
pas beaucoup il faut l'aider un bon mais
quand même il ya certains candidats qui
en parlent plus que d'autres
en tout cas nous on nous sommes une
association donc nous ne donnons pas de
consigne enfin nous ne choisissons pas
de candidat mais nous disons que nous ne
voulons pas nous ne voulons pas en tout
cas les idées rétrogrades qui ramène les
femmes à la maison qui les considèrent
comme responsables de la sécurité ou de
des mauvaises des mauvais résultats de
votre action de victoire certains thèmes
nous sommes contre les idées rétrogrades
sexistes et homophobes du front national
d'ailleurs nous participons collectif
anti le pen
et voilà donc nous disons simplement aux
femmes et aux hommes aussi qu'il faut
être attentive et attentif au programme
à ce qui se dit pas seulement sur
l'égalité encore une fois entre les
femmes et les hommes
mais sur les conditions de vie concrète
qui sont proposés à travers les
programmes des candidates et des
candidats
alors il y aura également les
législatives et au lendemain des des
présidentielles est ce que vous irez
voir les différents candidats que nous
avons martinez qui sont à peu près une
trentaine
vous allez écrire à ses candidats pour
leur dire votre vision de la de la
société martiniquaise comment il doit
être bien sûr à chaque élection nous
sommes bien être impliqué dans la vie
dans tout ce qui est politique politique
concernant la population et les femmes
et donc nous interpellons régulièrement
donc nous allons été appelé les
candidates et les candidats
sur leur lieu dit également qu'il y à
une loi sur la parité qu'il pourrait
faire par exemple attention candidat
qu'il présente aux élections
oui bien sûr mais ce n'est pas seulement
la parité statistiques qui est
importante
ce sont aussi les politiques qui sont
proposés en direction de la population
donc les deux vont de pair et c'est en
cela que nous allons interpeller les
candidates et les candidats pour les
prochaines législatives
oui dans certaines il ya beaucoup à
faire au niveau des lois mais aussi en
martinique très concrètement dans
certaines collectivités lorsque vous
suivez les plénières de ces communautés
d'agglomération bien à l'assemblée de
martinique vous n'êtes pas un peu
surprise de voir qu'il ya beaucoup de
femmes c'est la parité mais des femmes
qu'on entend quasiment jamais sans appel
oui encore une fois la parité c'est un
moyen d'accéder à l'égalité mais ce
n'est pas l'égalité donc dans notre dans
nos orientations
nous avons l'intention justement de
développer cet axe sur les politiques
publiques sur l'interpellation des élus
et des élus également par rapport à leur
participation et à ce qu'on pourrait à
ce qu'ils et elles pourraient faire pour
améliorer la condition des femmes en
martinique
donc oui ça n'est pas facile d'être une
femme et lui jusqu'à maintenant on n'est
pas toujours prise au sérieux certains
d'ailleurs ne sont pas suffisamment
formés pour briguer quand on va demander
aux hommes d'être aussi fort mais on va
trouver que ça sera normal on ne demande
pas aux hommes d'être plus fort mais
nous pensons que ce n'est pas seulement
une question de formation
c'est aussi une question de solidarité
quelquefois c'est aussi une question de
pouvoir s'exprimer de pouvoir exprimer
ses opinions d'avoir le courage
quelquefois de dire des choses qui vont
à l'encontre de ce qui se dit et c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas naturel chez les
femmes c'est plus dans notre éducation
il est plus facile aux hommes de prendre
la parole qu'aux femmes
donc ce sont des attitudes qui se
retrouve avec effectivement toujours au
niveau des femmes élues mais il faut
continuer vous savez la parité a ouvert
des brèches et il faut continuer parce
que c'est comme cela que nous allons
arriver à une véritable égalité merci
d'adresser se battait avec nouri tableau
d'heure présidente de l'union des femmes
de martinique depuis 2009 merci mon dieu
merci à vous
[Musique]